des salles trop petites une peinture
vieillissante et une connexion limitée
voilà quelques-uns des problèmes du
collège albert einstein équipes
éducatives et parents d'élèves ont
alerté sur la dégradation du bâtiment
lors d'un conseil d'administration
alexandra rosetti conseillère
départementale a porté la voix auprès du
président des yvelines on voit bien que
en termes de sécurité c'est pas du tout
optimum vu la taille des salles vu le
manque de sorties de secours en terme
d'électricité en terme de deux réseaux
de tout le monde c'est vrai commencé à
tirer la sonnette d'alarmé
donc
je pense que c'était c'était bien qu'on
puisse réagir et je suis ravi que le
président est soit venu visiter de
lui-même pour constater qu'effectivement
ce n'était pas exagéré le président du
conseil départemental pierre bédier a
donc visité le bâtiment d'une
quarantaine d'années construit pour
accueillir initialement 600 élèves
il ne peut en recevoir plus de 475 la
rénovation sera totalement prise en
charge par le département
coût total des travaux plus de 6
millions d'euros
on va faire les espaces extérieurs
agrandir le parking des profs refaire
une
une cour je pense qu'on peut dire de
récréation au collège
ensuite nous allons restructurer un
restructurer les salles de classe
lorsqu'elles sont trop petites
refaire a naturellement tous les
couloirs les revêtements
une restructuration qui s'intègre dans
un projet plus large le département
prévoit de rénover 20 établissements
d'ici 2021 à magny les hameaux les
travaux débuteront dès cet été